Os voy a hacer una pregunta, y no vale buscarlo
en Google ¿Cuál es la ciudad más cara del
planeta?
Seguramente estaréis pensando en Nueva York,
Hong Kong o tal vez Zurich, en Suiza… ¡Pues
nada de eso!
La ciudad más cara del mundo es LUANDA y
es la capital de ANGOLA, en África.
Para que os hagáis una idea, si queréis
alquilar un apartamento en Luanda, podéis
llegar a pagar la friolera de 5000 dólares
al mes ¿El precio de un menú Big Mac?
19 dólares.
Y si queréis tener internet en casa, ya podéis
ir preparando la cartera porque os costará
unos 300 dólares al mes.
Y os preguntaréis ¿Qué está pasando en
Angola?
¿Se trata de un país millonario en mitad
de África?
¡Pues nada de eso!
Por supuesto que la República Angola es uno
de los principales exportadores de petróleo
del mundo.
Superan a países como Qatar, por ejemplo.
Sin embargo, la mitad de su población ni
siquiera tiene acceso a agua potable.
2 de cada 3 niños angoleños sufren de malnutrición.
Y 1 de cada 6 muere antes de cumplir los 5
años.
Mientras tanto, Angola es el hogar de una
de las mujeres más ricas del mundo, Isabel
Dos Santos, que por cierto, es también la
hija del presidente del país, Jose Eduardo
Dos Santos.
A estas alturas, ya os habréis dado cuenta
de lo que pasa aquí.
Angola es uno de los países más corruptos
del mundo.
Y también, uno de los fiascos financieros
más colosales de los últimos años.
Muchas empresas han perdido auténticas fortunas
en este país.
En fin, supongo que no estaréis sorprendidos.
A fin de cuentas, Angola no deja de ser un
país del tercer mundo ¿Verdad?
Sin embargo, hay una pregunta ¿Cómo han
llegado hasta aquí?
¿Cómo es posible que un país llegue a una
situación semejante?
Y lo que es más importante ¿Cómo es posible
que el partido político que gobierna Angola
continúe, ganando elecciones con porcentajes
que superan el 70%?
Hoy, vamos a responder a estas preguntas,
pero antes, vamos a ver un poco de historia.
DIAMANTES, SANGRE Y DIPLOMACIA
Lo primero que tenemos que entender cuando
hablamos de África es que, casi todos los
países de la zona estuvieron colonizados
durante siglos por países europeos.
Bélgica, Francia o Portugal invadieron casi
todo el continente imponiendo gobiernos despóticos
y tratando a los ciudadanos nativos como si
fueran poco más que ganado.
Angola no se quedó atrás.
Hasta el año, 1975, Portugal ganó mucho dinero
explotando los diamantes que había en el
país.
Sin embargo, en ese año 1975, el gobierno
portugués reconoció la independencia de
Angola después de recibir toda clase de presiones
tanto por parte de la ONU como de los propios
portugueses.
Pero la pregunta es ¿Qué pasa después de
que un país se descolonice?
¿Quién se hace cargo del gobierno después
de que se vayan los colonos europeos?
Pues bien en lugar de responder a esta pregunta
celebrando unas elecciones, las distintas
tribus de Angola formaron facciones y se enfrentaron
en una guerra civil.
Hablamos de un conflicto que se prolongó
por más de 25 años.
Para que os hagáis una idea, todavía hoy,
hay zonas en el país donde no se puede caminar
porque están cubiertas de minas antipersona.
Por si alguien no sabe lo que son las minas
antipersona, se trata de unas bombas que se
esconden debajo de la tierra y que explotan
cuando alguien las pisa.
Y os preguntaréis ¿Cómo es posible que
en un país tan pobre, pudieran pagar todo
este armamento?
Pues bien, la respuesta está en los diamantes.
Los distintos bandos de la guerra angoleña
vendían estos diamantes a cambio de armas.
Pero… ¿Quién las suministraba?
Pues bien, a partir del año 1976, que es
cuando podemos hablar de una guerra civil
en toda regla, teníamos dos bandos en este
país.
Por un lado, estaba el llamado UNITA, que
dominaba el sur del país.
A UNITA lo apoyaba Sudáfrica, China y, en
menor medida Estados Unidos.
No olvidéis que estábamos en la Guerra Fría.
Cualquier conflicto era una oportunidad para
ganar influencia y debilitar al enemigo.
Y además, ya se sabía que Angola tenía
grandes cantidades de petróleo por explotar.
Y por eso mismo, la Unión Soviética no se
quedó atrás y decidió apoyar al Movimiento
Popular de Liberación Angoleña, liderado
por el actual presidente, Eduardo Dos Santos.
Por supuesto, Dos Santos contaba con el apoyo
de la Unión Soviética.
Pero, sin duda alguna, el país que más se
volcó en influir en la política de Angola
fue CUBA.
Fidel Castro no sólo vendió armas a Dos
Santos sino que también envió más de 30.000
tropas al país ¡Pero no sólo eso!
Durante los años 80, la zona que controlaba
este Movimiento de Liberación Popular de
Angola, recibió ingenieros y médicos de
Cuba.
Y eso explica, en parte, por qué Dos Santos
terminó ganando este conflicto.
De hecho, en los años 90, aunque la guerra
no había terminado, este hombre controlaba
prácticamente todo el país.
Sin embargo, estas ayudas cubanas no fueron
tan útiles como podríais pensar.
Por ejemplo, los ingenieros agrónomos de
La Habana intentaron cultivar caña de azúcar
en las tierras angoleñas.
Pero… al parecer este tipo de cultivos intensivos
no debían de ser lo más indicado para el
tipo de terreno que hay en el país.
Así que, en pocos años, las tierras de cultivo
de Angola quedaron completamente inútiles
para la agricultura.
Eso significaba más hambrunas para los angoleños,
que empezaban a estar un poco hartos de esa
ayuda cubana.
Por si esto fuera poco, tras el colapso de
la Unión Soviética, Eduardo Dos Santos se
da cuenta de que es mejor llevarse bien con
los países capitalistas.
A fin de cuentas, son los que pueden comprar
petróleo.
Por otra parte, Estados Unidos llevaba años
sin enviar ningún de apoyo a los guerrilleros
de la UNITA ¿Así, qué más necesitaba para
poderse llevar bien con el llamado mundo libre?
Pues muy sencillo.
Basta con quitar la palabra “marxista”
de tu vocabulario y sustituirla por el término
“democracia liberal”.
Y sí, le pongo todas las comillas del mundo
porque el capitalismo angoleño es un sistema aparte...
DEMOCRACIA A LA ANGOLEÑA
El año 2002 es un punto clave en la historia
de Angola.
Eduardo Dos Santos firma la paz con sus adversarios.
Desde entonces, UNITA se convierte en un partido
político más, con derecho a presentarse
a las elecciones.
Y, por primera vez en la historia, los angoleños
descubren lo bonita que es la democracia ¡Pero
no sólo eso!
En este mismo año ocurre lo siguiente.
“British Petroleum descubre petróleo en
aguas profundas en la costa de Angola”
De repente, Angola se convierte en un gigante
del petróleo, que suministra toneladas de
zumo de dinosaurio a países como China o
Estados Unidos.
En sólo cinco años, Angola multiplica su
riqueza por 4.
“La capital de Angola ha sido reconstruída.
La arquitectura de los años 50 y 60 da paso
a nuevas torres de oficinas construídas por
el sector empresarial nacional y el gobierno”
Empresas como Exxon Mobile, en Estados Unidos
o BP, en Reino Unido, comienzan a invertir
en Angola.
Y, por supuesto, envían a ingenieros y trabajadores
para que vivan en la capital, Luanda.
Y esa gente quiere vivir en viviendas de calidad,
salir por bares y comprar productos como los
que compraría en sus países de origen.
Pero todo esto es prácticamente imposible
de encontrar en un país que, tan sólo unos
pocos años atrás, estaba en plena guerra
civil.
En otras palabras: la oferta era escasa y
la demanda no dejaba de subir.
Como resultado, los precios de los bienes,
vamos a decir, occidentales, subieron como
la espuma.
“Construída para albergar a 500.000 personas,
la capital de angola alberga ahora mismo alrededor
de 5 millones.
Incluso los funcionarios, con buenos salarios,
tienen problemas para llegar a fin de mes”.
¡Pero esperad un momento porque hay mucho
más!
Imaginad que tenemos una empresa constructora
en China y queremos levantar un edificio de
viviendas en Luanda.
Pues bien, lo primero que tendríamos que
hacer es registrar una empresa en Angola.
Pues bien, ese proceso puede llegar a durar
más de 6 meses.
Durante ese tiempo, es perfectamente normal
que el gobierno encuentre montones de problemas
legales.
Necesito este papel, tienes que rellenar este
registro.
En definitiva, la clase de problemas que sólo
pueden solucionarse deslizando un buen fajo
de billetes.
Según varios informes de transparencia internacional,
prácticamente todas las empresas que han
hecho negocios en Angola han tenido que pagar
algún tipo de soborno al gobierno ¡Pero
esperad porque la cosa no termina aquí!
Todas esas grandes petroleras como Exxon Mobile
o British Petroleum, que querían explotar
el petróleo angoleño, tenían que asociarse,
o bien con el gobierno, o bien con la petrolera
estatal de Angola.
Se trata de una gran corporación que se llama
SONAGOL.
Y a que no adivináis quién es actualmente
la presidenta de esta empresa ¡Efectivamente!
Isabel Dos Santos, la hija del Eduardo Dos
Santos que fue presidente del país durante 40 años.
Cosas como esta explican porque Isabel Dos
Santos ha conseguido llegar a ser la mujer
más rica de África en pocos años.
“Todas las grandes inversions de Dos Santos
en Angola provienen, o bien de quedarse con
una parte del negocio de una empresa extranjera
en el país, o bien de convencer al presidente
para que les de permiso para hacer negocios”
Todo esto mientras el gobierno de Dos Santos
padre restringía el acceso a casi todos los
periodistas internacionales que querían contar
lo que ocurre en el país.
De hecho, casi todos los casos de corrupción
que se conocen en Angola, han aparecido gracias
a las investigaciones del gobierno de Reino
Unido o Estados Unidos.
Por supuesto, con este clima político, ningún
angoleño ha podido montar ninguna empresa.
A fin de cuentas, hace falta ser millonario para poder
pagar todos esos sobornos que exigía el gobierno.
Para que os hagáis una idea, dejando a un
lado todo el coste de la corrupción, sólo
con los gastos en trámites burocráticos,
necesitaríamos gastarnos más de 1000 dólares
para poder montar un bar en Luanda.
En un país tan pobre como Angola, esos 1000
dólares son un auténtico lujo.
¡Pero no sólo eso!
Esas empresas internacionales tampoco estaban
dispuestas a invertir más allá de lo justo
y necesario para poder extraer el petróleo.
¿Y todo esto qué consecuencias
ha tenido para el país?
Pues, básicamente, que Angola sólo produce
petróleo.
Los únicos negocios que se han hecho en Angola
han sido plantas de extracción y casas para
la gente que trabaja en las petroleras.
En el año 2014, el petróleo suponía el
97% de las exportaciones de este país.
¿Os suena de algo esta historia?
Si lleváis tiempo suscritos a VisualPolitik,
seguro que estaréis pensando en un país
que tenía una economía muy parecida ¡Exacto!
Hablamos de Venezuela.
Y al igual que en el país de Nicolás Maduro,
en el momento en el que el precio del barril
del petróleo cayó en el mercado internacional,
Angola se fue al traste.
Y ahora, volvemos al ejemplo de la constructora
China.
Muchas empresas de este país, invirtieron
millones en construir barrios enteros para
todos esos profesionales que venían a trabajar
en el sector petrolero de Angola.
Pero como ya no hay sector petrolero, tampoco
hay trabajadores.
“Autopistas sin coches, escuelas sin estudiantes,
durante 5 años, una empresa china construyó
Calumba usando líneas de crédito pagadas
entre China y el petróleo de Angola.
Pero parte de Calumba parece hoy una ciudad
fantasma”
En definitiva, que sólo hay un beneficiado
en toda esta historia.
Esa persona es José Eduardo Dos Santos y
su hija Isabel, que ya se han encargado de
hacer una fortuna y de invertirla en empresas
de todo el mundo.
Casi todas las grandes empresas portuguesas,
desde GALP hasta UNITEL, están controladas
por esta familia.
Si Portugal fue la potencia colonizadora de
Angola, hoy en día se ha convertido en la
lavadora de dinero.
Se estima que las élites angoleñas han sacado
unos 190 mil millones de dólares fuera del
país en los últimos 10 años.
Y mientras el país está en crisis, Isabel
Dos Santos, que en su cuenta de twitter se
autodenomina “EMPRENDEDORA”, se codea
con famosos como Kim Kardashian.
Con este panorama, os podéis imaginar que
la popularidad de la familia Dos Santos no
es demasiado alta ¿Verdad?
Sin embargo, su partido político, este Movimiento
Popular de Liberación Angoleña, continúa
arrasando en las elecciones con porcentajes
de voto que superan el 70%.
Sin ir más lejos, este mes de agosto han
tenido nuevos comicios y han vuelto a ganar
con resultados estúpidamente altos.
¿Cómo se puede explicar esto?
Pues me temo que nunca lo llegaremos a saber.
“Angola rechaza tener observadores de la
Unión Europea en sus elecciones”
Y ahora la pregunta es ¿Podrá algún día
Angola deshacerse de esa élite corrupta que
les gobierna?
¿Pueden seguir el camino de otros leones
africanos como Ghana o Ruanda?
Podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los comentarios.
Mientras tanto, si queréis saber lo que está
ocurriendo en el país vecino, en SUDÁFRICA,
haced click en este otro vídeo.
Y como siempre, si queréis estar al tanto
de lo que ocurre en el mundo, incluído África,
en VisualPolitik publicamos vídeos todas
las semanas.
Así que suscribíos al canal para no perderos
ninguna de nuestras actualizaciones.
Si os ha gustado este vídeo, dadle a LIKE
y nos vemos en el próximo.
Un abrazo y hasta pronto!